vous avez suivi à lucas landais
rassemblement initié par les gilet jaune
la manifestation est arrivé à son point
de destination finale place de la
bastille
absolument les manifestants sont en
train de se disperser ici sur la place
de la bastille la marche a duré environ
quatre kilomètres il ya eu quelques tirs
de gaz lacrymogène ici l arrivée place
de la bastille car une partie des
manifestants qui se trouvaient en tête
du cortège ont essayé de déborder le
dispositif de sécurité et vous voyez ici
tout est calme désormais liberté c'est
le slogan qu'ont scandé les manifestants
des manifestants qui sont toujours
opposés aux passera bitar une mesure
qu'il considère comme liberticide
tyrannique mais mais désormais ils ont
une autre inquiétude la possibilité que
cette vaccination puisse devenir
obligatoire pour tous le gouvernement
n'a pas fermé la porte à cette
éventualité je vous propose d'écouter
quelques manifestants avec qui j'ai pu
parler au début de ce cortège on ne
comprend pas pourquoi
la stratégie du gouvernement c'est de
vacciner tout le monde qu'on a on a pu
voir dans d'autres pays aux états unis
en israël en islande à malte que là où
il y avait des taux de vaccinations très
élevé et bien une nouvelle vague de
pandémie sévices et alors les certitudes
du gouvernement dans ce domaine ça me ça
me laisse pantois je pense que là on a
ouvert la boîte de pandore et ce qui
m'inquiète en fait c'est pour ça que je
suis ici c'est surtout l'avenir
par exemple est ce que il faudra un jour
montrer qu'on n'a pas de sanitaires
quand on veut faire un emprunt bancaire
voilà donc là je trouve qu'on est dans
une dérive qui est très très inquiétante
et effectivement l'obligation pour tous
c'est quelque chose qui m'inquiète c'est
pas sanitaires on n'en veut pas parce
qu'il n'a aucune raison d'exister le peu
de liberté qui sont les nôtres encore
aujourd'hui celle d'être dans la rue
pour dire stop on en a ras-le-bol on
veut vraiment la garder cette liberté
selon un sondage aux hawks à 67% des
personnes interrogées
étaient favorables aux pass sanitaire
11% d'entre ne voulait pas se faire
vacciner et 7 % d'entre eux ne voulaient
pas se faire vacciner y compris si la
vaccination devenait obligatoire cette
journée elle est importante pour les
opposantes au pass sanitaire parce que
le mois d'août a été marqué par des
baisses de fréquentation il y à une
manifestation prévue à paris le 11
septembre où les opposants pas sanitaire
espère fédérer un maximum et en
attendons que les chiffres de cette
mobilisation de ce huitième samedi
consécutif de mobilisation merci
beaucoup à lucas léger on